hello we're gonna go and hike bindi  irwin doesn't have to just stick to  hiking and getting around by foot  anymore and that's because the 17 year  old officially has her driver's license  Dancing with the Stars champ posted this  pic to Instagram writing quote thank you  so much to constable Joshua little and  Queensland Police for testing me today  and giving me my license and how's this  for a sweet sentiment she took the test  in her dad's old car she adds quote it  was wonderful to take my test in st.  George and past the first time and in my  dad's giant old oh I am so excited no  word yet on if she's planning to get a  new set of wheels but we love seeing how  stoked she is just to have scored her  license yeah  you